with the clippers just running the  lakers  off the floor wow suffocating defense  and harold couldn't get the shot up this  is the clippers biggest lead of the game  george and nobody home in the corner  nope well there was someone there but it  was the official  wow there's a look at tyler  the new coach he was the leader and then  he moved over a chair to become the head  coach when doc was let go  now he's with the 76ers they're going to  have some fun with pg after this game  and he thought someone was over there  yeah  okay is that your story and you're  sticking with it  i always do here comes lebron morris is  now  out there markief morris with kuzma  harold